hello everyone i'm rich stocks in 1997 i
heard a cassette tape
by veterinarian and naturopathic
physician dr joel wallach the title that
message was dead doctors don't lie dead
doctors don't lie now the book and the
audio have sold hundreds of millions of
copies worldwide making it the most
popular health lecture in history
so not only did i begin following dr
wallach's nutritional and wellness
guidelines i began sharing his message
with everyone i knew
25 years later i'm still sharing dr
wallock's message i'm still following
his nutritional advice i believe it has
served me well has served my family my
children well i'm excited to share it
with you the full dead doctors don't lie
audios available free of charge on our
website
mineraldoctor.com
mineraldoctor.com there are several
other videos there as well but that
original audio
you can listen to it right there on the
website
we have two other websites that might be
of interest to some of you
for bible teaching i am also a bible
teacher we have rich stocks.org that's
rich stocks.org
and then i have a website dedicated to
those who want to reduce maintain and
control their weight i believe it'll be
a great help to many people that is
simple3slim.com
so on the mineraldoctor.com website
right there on the homepage there are
two things that i'm going to suggest you
do
number one
take the free health evaluation we've
had other videos where we talked about
dr wallock's mineral deficiency
chart the four health categories this is
how you determine
what your body really needs
every human body needs the 90 essential
nutrients but you might need more of
specific nutrients to address
specific problems challenges that you're
dealing with so take that free health
evaluation and then schedule your free
phone consultation with one of dr
wallach's associates that's at
mineraldoctor.com
[Music]
i want to talk to you about dr wallick's
plant derived minerals
why they're so effective
so why are dr wallick's products so
unique and so effective
this is the only known mine in the world
dr wallach has the only known mineral
mine in the world
with over 70 and it's up to 77
plant derived minerals minerals in a
plant-derived form
we talked about in another video why
that is so important because the human
body
is not designed to absorb minerals
in a metallic form
in a clay form in a rock form
plants can do that through a process
called photosynthesis plants can break
down minerals from a metallic form
and absorb and use those
human beings cannot
dr wallet jokingly says you can't get
all the nutrition you need
by simply licking on a rock okay
so
excuse me
so the plants
take the nutrients out of the soil we
eat the plants that is the way your body
is supposed to get the minerals
these plant derived minerals of dr
wallick's have a natural
negative electrical charge
that's important for two reasons first
it may enhance the transport the bio
bioavailability of other nutrients
secondly it may support the body's
natural
detoxification
and the toxins of heavy metals
secondly is this
and this is very important dr wallach
says all dirt is not the same in fact i
like the way he says it this way even
better he says all dirt
is not created equal
i like that
you know even if you planted a garden
from row to row
the nutritional content the mineral
content of the soil is going to vary
from row to row
field to field crop the crops state to
state
in dr wallach's lectures he puts up a
map of the united states and then a map
of the world and he shows
areas of the country and areas of the
world that suffer with higher
percentages
of certain health challenges
and he links it directly to nutritional
deficiencies
in the soil
all the soils are deficient we've known
that since 1936. we talked about that on
another video u.s senate document 264
which was written in the year 1936 said
our farm soils are depleted
of vital nutrients
so we've known that for a long time what
does that mean that means our foods are
starved of nutrition
but again it varies all dirt is not
created equal
and dr wallach has found
the only mineral mine in the world that
we know of i'm not going to say it's the
only one it's the only one that we are
aware of where you can get all
the minerals you need well how many do i
need again we talked about this on
another lesson
90 for life that means there are 90
essential nutrients but 60
here's the shocker 60 of the 90
are minerals
we hear about vitamins
vitamins vitamins vitamins i mentioned
on another video i threw my vitamins
under the bed when i was a kid
now men quote unquote the vitamin
business
but without these minerals vitamins have
no function in the human body
there's nothing for them to do
these minerals
are the sparks of electricity that cause
the vitamins to be utilized by the human
body
so what makes his products unique what
makes dr wallock's minerals different
from all the others the only known mine
in the world containing all 60
essential minerals in fact they're 70
up to 77. all right those are called
rare earths
they're in a plant-derived form so your
body can
absorb and utilize them it's a remote
location a very pristine environment
i've been there many times
in emory county utah no pollution
middle of nowhere to be quite honest
with you
and then if you'll go to our website
mineraldoctor.com i should have put an
image up for the video but i didn't do
that but if you'll go we have a picture
of that mineral mine and you can look at
the different layers it's interesting
they come in and they cut away the side
of a mountain
and here's all these different colors
you know just layer after layer
but it's different colors
well what are those different colors
they are different veins
of those minerals different minerals
have different colors do you know that
gold is a mineral has a different color
from silver so it makes sense you'll see
that picture on our website
and then above all the minerals and also
you'll see this in the picture
there is a layer of topsoil about 20 to
30 feet
and that's what preserved this mineral
mine
that is how it has been preserved there
for thousands of years
if
that layer of topsoil had been greater
the pressure would have turned the
minerals into coal
but if the layer of topsoil hadn't been
there
then
the minerals would have been washed away
by erosion so there's about 20 to 30
feet
in depth which is just enough to
preserve the plant deposit without
pressurizing it into coal or other
fossil fuels
so here's what they do here is how they
take it from the
mineral mine
into this bottle of product that i'm
going to be talking to you about just
here in just a moment
step number one is excavation of the
humic shale
this mineral deposit
it looks like rocks but when you get up
close to it
and you put some in your fingers it
actually becomes like a powder
and if you were to take that powder and
put it under a microscope you could
actually see
plants you would see that this is a
plant deposit it's called humic shale
humic shale is
non-fossilized plants naturally
containing
these 75 to 77 different minerals trace
minerals and rare earths
so that's step number two they simply
come in
cut away the side of the mountain step
number two they take this deposit
just like you would take a bag of tea if
you're a tea drinker
you take the bag of tea
and you soak it in water what happens
well eventually that water changes color
and what's inside that tea bag now is
blended in with your water and it
becomes one
the the tea granules inside the bag
are filtered into the water
and now you have tea
and again if you're a tea drinker you
know what this is well that's exactly
the way these minerals
they take these deposits
of the humic shell which just looks like
dirt but again remember all dirt was not
created equal they soak it in these huge
vats of liquid i forget how many days
they soak it for a period of time until
all of those nutrients all of those 60
70 77 minerals
naturally blend
with the water
and bond with the water then step number
three is the filtering process they take
that mineral solution
and they filter it
at what's called 0.5
micron 0.5
micron that's smaller than
most viruses
we used to say it like this in our
presentations
that that is small enough that is like
causing it to pass through a three inch
phone book
if something is .5 micron
and you filter it down that small
it's like passing through a three inch
phone book
why is that so important because then
none of the metallic minerals can get
through whatever passes through that
filtering process you know
is a very very small tiny particle
and so what is the end result the end
result is this product that i'm holding
in my hand right here
dr wallach's plant derived minerals this
is the basis this was his flagship
product this is the product that started
it all this is the product that he
talked about on the dead doctors don't
lie lecture simply plant derived
minerals there are no flavorings in this
you probably wouldn't want to take it
straight because it is just
it's not just like the mineral water you
know perrier or envion that you get in
the store where they say hey we've we've
added some minerals no
you taste this you're going to know it's
a little bit stronger than that but you
can mix it in anything a little bit of
juice a little bit of anything ut your
coffee but this is 100
pure plant derived minerals nothing else
certified organic
contains 77
trace minerals
and rare earths
here's here's the catch right here
here's what makes it different from all
the others 7
000 to 10 000 times smaller
than a red blood cell
i'm going to say that again the minerals
contained in this liquid solution
are 7 000 to 10 000 times smaller than a
red blood cell why is that so important
for absorption
the smaller the particle the easier for
your body
to absorb
and dr wallet guarantees the amount
that's in each bottle 19 000 milligrams
contained in every bottle and he
guarantees it
i've had a friend who owns
or used to own a whole network of
laboratories across the country was one
of the largest
in the country and when he heard dr
wallach's message actually had some of
these products tested it's not
cheap to do that but he wanted to do it
and was well satisfied with the results
what we say is in the bottle dodge
wallet guarantees well you put all of
those things together
the fact that they're plant derived the
particles are so small you come up with
a product that is 90 to 98 percent
absorbable by the human body where a lot
of products you might get
you might only absorb four percent 12
percent or even if it's a chelated
mineral people talk about oh this helps
absorption it does but you're still
going to only absorb maybe 40 whereas
this pure plant-derived
mineral product you're going to get 90
to 98
absorption from this all right so we are
out of time for today visit our website
mineraldoctor.com
take the free health evaluation
schedule your free phone consultation
and we are looking forward to hearing
from you and hearing the great results
you're going to experience from dr
wallex products very soon